Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya is a Russian
attorney and if he recognized the name
that's because in 2016 she became famous
for meeting briefly with Donald Trump
jr. remember this was the smoking gun of
Russian collusion that you heard about
endlessly for months and months on cable
news
well that one meeting was going to bring
down the administration if you were
conducting an investigation into Russian
influence in the 2016 election vessel in
that sky of course would be will be one
of the very first people you would talk
to obviously so how is this for weird in
a recent interview with The Associated
Press vessel Messiah the same one says
that she was never even contacted by
Special Counsel robert muller she's done
no interviews with any federal
investigators she says haha how can that
be well if it's true it's shocking but
it's only shocking if you still think
this investigation is actually about
russian collusion if it is then ignoring
vessel in the sky does not make sense
but of course this investigation isn't
really about collusion or russia and it
never was it was an attempt to undo
election results from day one we didn't
want to think that didn't want to come
to that conclusion but now it is too
obvious to ignore Joel Paine is former
director of african-american advertising
and Hillary for America nuances central
thanks for coming on good to be with you
so look I there's a lot we don't know so
I'm taking vessel in that sky whom I've
never met and know nothing about at her
word that she wasn't contacted by
investigators if that's true stipulating
if it's true there's no other
explanation other than Muller isn't
really after more than a year and a half
looking into Russian collusion because
how could you skip her well if we're
gonna take this lawyer at her word we've
got to take Bob Muller at his word and
that and at what he's done that he has
been very responsible with this
investigation and that there's probably
a reason why she hasn't been contacted
yet I mean the investigations not done I
imagine that if she has something that's
material to the case that they determine
his material to the case that they'll
talk to her serial to the case I mean
she is the case at least as it's been
understood publicly there been a ton of
leaks from the Moller investigation so
we know a lot she met with the president
he like leaks today because we don't
usually like leaks usually we like it
well I'm a journalist so I actually like
I want always but they discredit
investigation because investigations law
enforcement is not supposed to yeah but
I always want to know I mean my
positions never change them that but
here's the point ignoring her isn't
possible if what you're trying to
discover is whether or not the Russians
played a role in the outcome of the 2016
election so I think we know for certain
this investigation whatever else it is
isn't really about that we were lied to
it's about something else
so shouldn't we be well should we just
pause and say wait a second what is this
sucker I got to disagree with you look
Muller has even even the parts of this
case that don't have anything to do a
collusion he's referred to the
appropriate jurisdictions the southern
court in New York you know that Bob
Muller is a man of high regard he is he
has been lauded by Democrats and
Republicans allow care for managing
mister you don't care about it but it
shows that he has managed this case the
way that he should manage it and let's
not lose sight your no I'm not attacking
Muller I have never once attacked him I
never will attack him unless there's
cause to do it I'm just concerned that
the rest of us were sold on the idea
that we needed to investigate whether
Russia hacked our election hacked our
democracy the other channels went
wall-to-wall for over a year on that
telling our country we have we went to
war with Russia as a result we killed
hundreds of Russians in Syria as a
result now it's starting to look like
that's not even in play it's not even
relevant it was never about that why
shouldn't I feel lied to
well you shouldn't feel lied to because
three members of the president's team
three very significant members of the
president's campaign team have already
acknowledged that they had a role in
wrongdoing they've already their
complete attention they we don't we
don't know that you may know exactly we
don't know what the full scope of the
investigation but I've read the
indictments of those three members all
metaphore Tucker I've ran he ran the
campaign the campaign that we're
difficult appleís didn't you know
whatever but here's the point
none of them pled to anything having to
rush inclusion here's my question to you
if at the end of all this assuming it
ever does end sure we discovered that
nobody is charged for colluding with
Russia and there's no actual evidence
that Russia colluded won't you have
cause to feel lied
you know I personally know and I know
part of what you wanted to talk about
here was the DNC loss yeah and I'll
bring that up in this regard the DNC is
trying to push the discussion the public
dialogue about making sure that we never
have a situation like this happen again
we had a foreign government try to
compromise the results of our election
well that's never allow that but that's
and anybody regardless of who you voted
for
should care about that really so they
care about it so so then then why does
the DNC push electronic voting the only
way to secure your voting against
foreign interference in a foolproof ways
with paper ballots and yet the DNC
consistently pushes against that they
don't care at all about foreign
interference this has nothing to do with
that if they really cared they would be
for paper ballots but they're not why
aren't that Tucker I disagree with
electronic voting issue in everything
yes your your is not in complaining
apples and oranges here you're saying I
should be concerned about foreign
government I'm having our elections I'm
saying the number one way they do that
is electronically why don't we have
paper ballots any security person has
ever looked at this comes to conclusion
paper ballots are the way you protect
yourself things on my walk home I'm not
blaming the fact that there's a light
out two blocks away I'm blaming the fact
that somebody mugged me and I want to
figure out why they did it and I want to
get to the bottom of but maybe you
should stop to continue your metaphor
stop taping a hundred dollar bills tear
forehead because it increases the risk
that's my point if you really are afraid
any security let me ask you this last
question the DNC is taking a position
that it ought to be illegal to publish
accurate information if that information
has been taken from an email account
that would have prevented the Pentagon
Papers not they would take it from an
email account but it was private
information published publicly but it
was accurate why would the DNC be
attacking freedom of the press in this
way there's no other way to read them
again Tucker you know good and well that
the NC is not attacking freedom of the
press the DNC is trying to do what the
president has decided not to do which is
get to the bottom of why our take on it
is deflection really cuz NC
during the issue Oh the DNC is saying it
ought to be illegal to publish these
emails I think that's what they're
saying saying that in the absence of
presidential leadership we are going to
push the issue [ __ ] through another way
did it be and they and by the way
they've done this before they did it
against Nixon they've they've sued they
sued to learn information about what
happened to having been illegal as the
DNC suggests for news organization as to
not watch the DNC is suggesting that we
just disagree on on what we were I'm
just taking him at face value I get
maybe metaphorically they're not
suggesting that but literally I think
they're saying that I Tucker you know
good and well that's a group of freedom
of the press you should go look they're
just gonna take a look at who's sitting
in slit Joel thank you always